let's bring in senator Ted Cruz fresh
off his quarantine Ted the president
states yesterday in a letter to
America's governor's he's going to
basically give them an idea of he's
gonna grade some of these counties on
how dangerous they are an overrun they
are with this coronavirus and the ones
that are untouched maybe he's gonna try
to gradually phase in economic progress
again are you for a phase-in standing
America up again or just keep it locked
down till we have it more under control
well listen I think any health response
needs to deal with the facts on the
ground and then the facts the ground are
different from one location to another
and so I think our approach to this
global pandemic we need to be guided by
the science we need to be Gluck guided
by the physicians and medical
professionals and I fully expect the
circumstances are different in Manhattan
than perhaps they are in rural Idaho and
and and so you wouldn't expect the exact
same rules to apply everywhere I think
that's that recognizes the diversity of
the country and where there is an
outbreak where there is a direct and
serious threat of course steps need to
be taken to protect lives but but those
can vary in different parts of the
country exactly right and in fact
senator Cruz the president last night
said that Nebraska Texas your state Iowa
farm belt some parts might be able to
open up sooner than others of course the
entire country is looking to Congress
and I know that the corona rescue bill
has already passed your chamber the
Senate but you know it's questionable
what's gonna happen with the bill today
because as we heard this hour there's
one congressman he's a Republican from
Kentucky his name is Thomas Massie he is
opposed to the bill because it would add
to the national debt and he's concerned
that voting without a quorum president
would violate the Constitution the
problem is when you have members of
Congress flying back from all over the
country they're in airports are going to
be back into the chambers it does seem
as if you are putting members of
Congress at risk to do this even though
we know everybody knows is this thing
gonna pass yeah you know I would not be
terribly concerned about
about the procedural question it's clear
the house is gonna pass it's clear the
house is gonna pass it with an
overwhelming bipartisan majority if it
so happens that a member 2 or 3 decides
they want to vote no well they could
they can do that Thomas's believe
strongly in his principles I saw also
Alexandria ok Joe Cortez tweet out that
she was unhappy that the checks that are
there going out the the $1,200 relief
checks that they're not going to illegal
immigrants and she was unhappy about
that but people can have their
disagreements this is gonna pass it's
gonna pass overwhelmingly which means
relief is going to be in the hands of
the people that are hurting and and in
the Senate the day before yesterday we
passed it unanimously it was 96 to
nothing every single senator Republican
and Democrat voted yes Bernie Sanders
voted yes so did I and everybody in
between and and the reason listen this
is a two trillion dollar bill that's
about a tenth of our national debt that
is a big deal that's not something that
would pass in any ordinary ordinary
circumstances but but these are
extraordinary circumstances the
magnitude of the health threat is is
massive and that and the magnitude of
the economic threat we lost three and a
half million jobs last week small
businesses are shuttering all across
this country and so this emergency
relief package is designed to put real
relief in the hands of people the two
most important parts of it are that
every person making $100,000 or less or
every couple making $200,000 or less
will get a check in the mail a check in
the mail for $1,200 per adult $2,400 per
couple and $500 per child all of those
checks should be coming out the Treasury
Department tells us in the next two to
three weeks secondly for small
businesses
there's 377 billion dollars in loans
guaranteeing loan that are designed that
it's for businesses five hundred
employees or less so small businesses up
to ten million dollars each and the
loans and if they use the loans to pay
for payroll to keep their employees on
payroll if they use the loan
for mortgage or rent or utilities those
loans will be forgiven that's designed
to be an immediate infusion of cash for
the restaurant for the bar for the nail
salon for the movie theater the hardware
store all the small businesses and the
way you get it if you're a small
business owner you go to your local bank
or community financial institutions it
will be administered through the local
banking system okay we only have one
minute I have two questions for you if
you furlough your employees can you
still get those benefits secondly how
you doing after self-quarantine on the
first point yes
if you rehire them so you can get the
benefits regardless but the loan is only
forgiven if you rehire the employee so
if you've already furloughed the
employees you can go and get the loan
rehire them and their payroll will be
forgivable okay hang on I'm doing
terrific I spent 11 days and
self-quarantine here at home and then I
left self-quarantine went to DC went to
the Senate was active and in in passing
this bill and I'm now back home with a
family bill and healthy and terrific and
and and working actively for both
excellent thank you so much senator for
being with us we're glad you're doing
well thank you god bless
you're welcome god bless you have a good
weekend